we got new merch some new colorways uh
in the be good to yourself collection
we've got hoodies in Plum and Moss we've
also got t-shirts in lilac moss and Blue
Mist hope you enjoy those those are good
colors
get that hitter and more at
theovinstore.com
today's guest has been a figure in most
of our lives
um he hosted a show called Dirty Jobs
where he just got involved in it all man
he's not afraid to to go to the beach
and sit in the quicksand you know
um he has been a narrator
uh you've heard his voice on shows like
Deadliest Catch and Shark Week he's an
activist for the trades and for regular
working people I'm grateful to have him
here today Mr Mike Rowe
oh
impossible stories
[Music]
[Applause]
house cleaning
Story of My Life man has it been
yeah and that and no did you do chores
growing up did you have any chores I had
uh all the like the classic chores right
we had um we had some land
that really wasn't ours but we had
access to and my mother was crazy for
horses so we built a barn and we had
three or four or five horses at any
given time that we boarded and the
average horse will crap eight times a
day oh wow so if you have five horses
each one crapping eight times a day
that's basically 40 loads right so I
come home from school first job was to
uh
to pick up the worst [ __ ] yeah right put
in the compost pile and then split wood
we had a our house was heated mostly
with a wood stove so my main chores from
August 13th to
18. we're picking up horse crap and
splitting wood
did you get to see him do the craps or
you just there was already done when you
got there I played a game called bonus
points right so I mean normally when you
come home The Field's just full of
little loads of turds and you scoop them
up with your wheelbarrow but if you
catch one in the midst and if you can
get over and get the shovel yeah under
its ass the sound that the turd makes
when it lands on the shovel yeah weirdly
satisfying you know and you start you're
looking over your shoulder when you're
out there waiting for the next one and
really it's strange you know I'm older
now than I've ever been but I do the
same thing with my dog when I'm walking
the dog and I see him spin it's
ridiculous you're like a grown man with
a plastic bag in his hand but there I am
holding it under its assets catching it
in midair like Kirby pocket or whatever
just but no I could see that there's for
me I could totally see that there would
be value if I could like in my head it's
like oh if I can get a little more
efficient here and cut off the time
between isn't it crazy the games we play
and the little things we at least I do
yeah over the course of a day right it
could be making the light at the
intersection uh it could be you know the
perfect text the right tweet whatever
you assign value to but yeah it's funny
I hadn't thought about it that way but
at that point in my life one of the most
satisfying things to do was to catch a
turd in midair yeah God simple things oh
I think in some countries it's still
probably is a damn it's probably a dang
Olympic sport if you get out there into
some places
oh yeah I think I mean who knows where
things will go I think that
entertainment's getting pretty out there
you think I mean geez you know what I
did the other night man I'm flicking
around not knowing what I'm looking for
yeah and I stumble across the national
cornhole championship
grown men them Bag Boys yeah I mean I
it's like seven or eight straight in the
hole no sliding no nothing just nailed
it we I feel like when I watch that I
can feel their wives in the distance
being like get a [ __ ] job right now
Darren so proud of you Darren so proud
of you with your little bean bag and
your little hole we're proud of you but
Tiffany needs her daddy at home
you know what I'm saying you could fit
because you know I don't think the
money's there yet we're like but it's
this it's the same it's like as a kid I
remember flicking around and watching
bowling yeah like Earl Anthony Jr
bowling and it was the most I mean the
intensity and the focus yeah and it
wasn't a big crowd but it was an Engaged
crowd you know and the way the announcer
would step in there and oh my God the
pressure is high and here he is and the
focus and the concentration it's the
same thing with darts yeah I love darts
and it's like so there are so many of
these little hobby type things
get treated like it's the decathlon yeah
and if you're just a guy flicking around
in the middle of the night and you
stumble across there he is man bushes
tossing the look at that right in there
like it had eyes that bean baby right
there yeah and now what kind of beans
are in the bag I wonder maybe that's how
Bush does it you know what that would be
amazing somebody should open up a bag
and see if bush beans are in there I cut
open a golf ball once when I was a kid
one of my grandfather's shop and put a
golf ball in a vise and I took a hacksaw
and I opened it up and it was Newton I
I really it didn't occur to me that at
the time I was just like Isaac Newton
but you're right there I was looking
inside the golf ball like it was some
microcosm of the uh of the solar system
and peeling these rubber bands away and
you know oh there's rubber bands in
there oh well there's something rubber
they look like rubber bands but they're
really dense and they're really thin and
they're wrapped really really tight
around this this nucleus in the center
of its marble type little thing huh but
you know some guys at home trying to
find a better way to make a better golf
ball
yeah knowing full well that some
knucklehead who's been amusing himself
by catching [ __ ] in midair is going to
take one put it in a vice and cut it
open and see what makes the world
what uh what's keeping you busy these
days sitting here with Mike Rowe thanks
so much for coming in sure
um
and congratulations for uh for being in
Nashville and for carving out a carving
out a piece of something real I mean
this is so you know I do a podcast too
keeps me pretty busy but I'm on the road
all the time so I'm doing it on like
Riverside or Zoom or you know and it's
not the same as you know sitting in an
upholstered chair with a guy in his
house with the you know it's it's like
cable access meets
okay yeah real I mean honestly like
we're this far from Wayne's World yeah
we are and people are watching like lots
of people are watching so congrats on
that oh thank you man yeah I think we've
been looking for different Studios
recently but there's a level of
not I don't want to there's a level of
rogueness that has to accompany a
podcast space yeah it's like in L.A
because we have a studio in LA and we've
been looking there and it's like man
this is a there's a Chase Bank in the
lobby that's not it we need like a
missing person poster within 60 feet
it's a need to be on the building but
you know what I'm saying there needs to
because there's a level still of grunge
to it you know right right um that I
think always needs to be there if I walk
into a corporate place I in my head feel
more corporate and so it puts me in a
different headspace um so I'd imagine it
does that for other folds but you can't
fake it right I mean if you're gonna be
in a corporate space there's a way to
behave that's consistent with your
surroundings and when people look at
that they might not like it but they're
not going to judge you for being a
sellout or a fake or a poser like you
don't think so huh well not I mean I'm
not I'm not saying that came off a
little uh what they might yeah think so
I came off a little bit Outsiders well I
mean it's like if when I see somebody uh
working hard to be grungy
I don't see it as much different than
somebody who's working hard to be
corporate if you're working hard
to create an appearance then you become
part of the production and if you're
part of the production then you're part
of the enemy to authenticity and I and
what I take from what you're saying is
that the thing that's for sale in the
podcast space that is also for sale you
know in any good comedians act uh in any
TV show that feels real and any song
that feels real
is authenticity yeah right and so
there's this weird trap if you if you
work really hard to create it well then
you're manufacturing it and that makes
you fake but if somehow or another you
can function in your space ask the
questions you want to ask give the
answers you want to give and a time
frame that you want to create you know
you then then I think people will at
least give you a listen right that's a
good point so maybe I'm over maybe I'm
giving that too much credit maybe you
know maybe like I know on dirty jobs
that
I mean I think the reason the show
lasted as long as it lasted was because
we never did a second take
it was I just said look if I'm gonna do
a reality show this is back before
reality meant something unreal yeah like
if we're if we're literally I mean you
came up in that world too yeah like look
we're not going to do any pre-production
We're not gonna do any writing we're not
going to do any real casting all we're
going to do is follow a guy around doing
his job and I'm gonna have a normal crew
and they're gonna shoot the show and
they're going to cut the show you know
however we agree to do it but I'm also
going to have a camera that never stops
rolling and I call it the truth Cam and
um you know like right now when I'm
looking at this that's camera a shooting
me walking and talking in this uh dump
actually down in uh down in San
Francisco but over my left shoulder
there's another camera that's rolling so
if that camera there suddenly craps the
bed or if I have an audio problem or a
plane flies over or I screw up my line
or something a dog attack anything
happens I can turn to the truth Cam and
I can tell you I can tell the viewer
here's what's happening right now I love
that right here's what's happening right
now and it and it wasn't planned and I I
just want you to feel like you're there
with me so that's that's reality yes if
and and and you don't need to do it like
every second you just have to remind the
viewer from time to like that there I am
smear that's actual [ __ ] I'm smearing on
the lens of the camera oh wow now that's
Japanese as heck Japanese and German
yeah we Dirty Jobs was always one click
away from a German porno right and
um
and I mean look at me that's me 20 years
ago wow right that crazy show is still
in there there again you see it that
that's you know that's actual mud
exploding from an oil well onto the lens
of the camera that that's chicken [ __ ]
squirted onto the lens of the camera
like oh yeah when you put stuff like
that into the viewer's face and there's
the truth cam oh yeah that's me showing
you what I'm seeing as it's happening
so that's all just a long way of saying
that you're you're doing a version of
that with this podcast you know you're
right we want to keep it as authentic as
possible yes because it really is what
the truth is I think so yeah you know it
has changed over the years a lot of
those shows now are so different it's so
it's just all so manufactured and the
algorithm has gotten so strong of us to
like what the uh what people want what
do they need it's like there's all these
testing points and stuff it just the
reality has gone out of a lot of stuff
and it's been replaced by feedback like
everybody it's normal to want to know
how you're doing yeah and you know back
when I used to do that show you know
there I am with my arm literally past my
elbow inside a cow and you know it's
deep huh it didn't occur what are you
trying to what is this part of uh is
this um this isn't one of those like uh
it's not like a crystal ball thing is it
I don't think so man I think that that
episode we were uh uh we were showing
the realities of artificial insemination
oh yeah and I was trying to make the
point that you know there there is no
McDonald's
there is no Carl's Jr there there are no
millions and millions of hamburgers
served every day without people coaxing
the sperm out of a bull and and getting
it into a cow yeah I mean it it's it's
so prevalent and so common
um in the places where it happens but
but so mysterious to most people hey
from one or the other yeah yeah get it
getting the you know I mean you're
talking about artificial vaginas you're
talking about uh styrofoam cups you're
talking about you know guiding the penis
of a bull called hun sucker Commando
into the right spot how big is it can
you put it around like a could you get
one hand all the way around it or not
yeah the Bulls are interesting it's like
a carrot and that's my garage door we
just heard just in case you you guys
heard that that's authenticity keeping
it real yeah you know what I did a I did
a podcast a couple of months ago and the
title of it was the leaf blower stays in
because there was a goddamn leaf blower
outside by window and I really I really
thought about I take a golf club and I
could go out and I just kill the guy you
know I can solve the problem because
he's not going to go away yeah right and
uh and eventually we just made him a
part of the show so um yeah whether it's
a leaf blower or the penis on a bull you
know some sometimes you just got to play
the cards you get yeah that's true
that's true yeah I think I'd rather play
the leaf blower I think the leaf blower
stays in no the uh how big is yeah could
you get your hand all the way around
that Wiener that's a good one right
there bovine reproductive so it's like
that it's not a it's not a big thick
vascular which one that uh that looks
like a dang um uh snowman nose huh
well the weather outside is fried it's
getting frightful now dude I'll tell you
that surprise dude if that thing got
loose in a school yard my God
see that's the kind of stuff we gotta
stop man all right so here's here's what
you're not seeing and and and here's
what we showed you on I guess it was
season three I don't remember which one
but we um you know before you grab the
penis like that and and direct it into a
repository you take a uh
you take a probe right it's about two
feet long looks like a shotgun mic okay
right and um and on the back of the
probe is a battery
um about size of a deck of cards and
hanging from the battery are these wires
right okay and the wires go into this
Tackle Box I called it The Tackle Box
from Amsterdam because it was full of
lube and it was just full of dials and
buttons it was a real curiosity you know
this farmer opens up The Tackle Box and
you look inside and you take out the
probe and you slather it up with lube
and then you walk to the the rear the of
the animal the male and you insert the
probe into its rectum all the way up to
the the battery at the end wow and so
you get it in there about a foot and a
half free coffee huh there's nothing
free brother in this life so you get it
so you get it all the way in there and
then you go back to the tackle box from
Amsterdam and you turn on the current oh
oh my God bro I didn't see that there it
is right there the ultrasound Scanner
with toe probes for rectal probe for
veterinary animal so is this part of Saw
isn't this saw season two I feel like
this is heavy bro so you guys were doing
all this so you run a a light amount of
current through the leads into the probe
and it stimulates the prostate of the
animal yeah now when this happens all
right so the cowboy is turning the knob
I have taken a position underneath
hunsucker Commando right and he hands me
this um
this Styrofoam cup he basically says you
want to be on the knob or you want to
hold the cup and I'm thinking well it's
TV is going to be more exciting if I
hold a cup yeah you got to be right
there you got to be that light yeah so
so the first the first knob since the
first blast to current into the prostate
and the bull whose name incredibly was
hun sucker Commando uh immediately
presents himself so that that carrot
shaped thing becomes uh turgid really
rigid right and then uh you grab it and
you point it towards toward the cup and
then he turns the second knob no and the
current really flows in there God and
this thing is with AAA who is this guy
Duracell no it's um I don't know I mean
at that point you're not asking a lot of
questions right you're you're squatting
underneath an enormous bull you're
holding its carrot-shaped penis yeah and
you've got a styrofoam cup toward the
tip
and the guy turns the second knob and
that current hits the prostate and then
he starts yelling at me uh what do you
say don't don't spill a drop Mike that's
white gold every drop is precious
so you fill up the Styrofoam cup wow and
do they put it on a scale after is it
like
see you turned it into an Olympic event
again
for the size of that load I'd put
sprinkles on mine I think this is
unbelievable hypo Dazzle mine
I want it to really pop in the afternoon
sun
so now you take the sperm from the cup
and you put it in this device and then
you take these things like pipettes it
looks like a stir that you get for your
coffee at Starbucks right yeah and the
sperm goes into these pipettes and then
you bring in the girls or actually you
go to them they'll be maybe 30 cows you
know all facing north and you're behind
them wow and you take this injector and
you put the pipette in there and you
reach all the way in right past the
vulva past the vagina past the cervix
till you get to the horns of the uterus
the horns of the uterus Mac we're there
error and you find that and you can you
and you situate the pipette and then you
pull the trigger and then you have
artificially inseminated a cow and does
she smile or anything is there any well
what I like to do I I'd light a candle
first little aromatherapy oh yeah and of
course you know a tasteful floral
bouquet something to set the mood
UFC 281 is live it's live from New York
this Saturday get closer to the octagon
with DraftKings sports book the official
sports betting partner of UFC right now
new customers can bet five dollars on
UFC 281 and get 200
and free bets that's a lot if your
fighter wins that's it
and check this out right now everyone
can earn up to a 100 boost with
DraftKings stepped up parlays assuming
you do not have a gambling problem
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
now use promo code t-h-e-o throw down
five dollars on UFC 281 and get two
hundred dollars in free bets if your
fighter wins that's code Theo this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of UFC
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details so the
other day I realized um I have a lot of
subscriptions going on that I haven't
even canceled yet or that have been
running in the background
I got in a damn haircut club or
something somebody put me into and
I don't even know where it's located and
I'm paying nine dollars a month for uh
trims but it's not just me eighty
percent of people have subscriptions
that they've forgotten about or can't
get out of that's why I love using
rocket money formerly known as true bill
the app that shows all your
subscriptions in one place and cancels
what you don't want for you that's right
rocket money can even find subscriptions
you didn't know you were paying for you
may even find out you've been double
charged for a subscription rocket money
handles that
to cancel a subscription all you have to
do is press cancel and Rocket money
takes care of the rest
rocket money will do it that's why I
love using them they're formerly known
as true bill
yep and right now you can get rid of
useless subscriptions with rocket money
go to
rocketmoney.com t-h-e-o
seriously it could save you hundreds of
dollars per year that's rocket
r-o-c-k-e-t-money.com slash
t-h-e-o now look man it's it's different
everywhere I was a place called Babcock
Ranch in Texas where we did the same
thing with uh quarter horses and
thoroughbreds and with that ponies No
Quarter Horse is a is a big animal that
runs the quarter mile okay as opposed to
a thoroughbred who would run you know
Belmont Stakes Preakness things yeah I
was just at kneeling yeah yeah they keep
changing the name of it but I was there
fast horses man fast horses well they
but the quarter horses are bigger now
they're about the same size okay they're
just um they're they're cardiovascular
systems are a little different they're
musculature is a little different
they're just bred to run faster for
shorter periods yeah little Urban but
they brought in this horse called paid
by chick I still don't know why they
called it that but this was season one
of dirty jobs you can find this too I'm
wearing a yellow bicycle helmet because
the day before a groom got kicked
unconscious oh why because he got
underneath the horse the wrong way look
it gets violent so the the horses let in
and then it it jumps on something called
a pommel horse like that's literally
where they go oh yeah I've seen those
things in the Olympics so the front legs
get on top of this thing now meanwhile
they bring in a mare in heat
so it's like you know in a handsome
animal so like it's like porn it's like
black beauty is let in she's in heat you
bring in the stallion oh yeah he jumps
up on the quarter horse and he just
starts thrusting in midair I mean he's
fully ready to go yeah and that's when
you step in
you meaning me with a yellow bicycle
helmet holding a an artificial vagina oh
like some kind of damn spunk minion it
looked
all right somebody make a note spunk
minion if that doesn't wind up on a hat
if you're not selling spunk minion hats
by this time next month I gotta talk to
your ad guys because you've missed a
real opportunity next on spunk minions
and so so you're hunched under this
animal and and and this is not like a
bull's little carrot penis this is a
full-on baby's arm holding an app you
have to rest on your shoulder or
anything like how heavy is it yeah well
you get your shoulder underneath the
animal then you grab the penis and you
slip it into the artificial vagina which
looks like a hot water bottle oh yeah
and now here's the craziest part about
that on the other side of the artificial
vagina you've got a baby bottle like a
formula baby bottle that screws in and
inside that baby's bottle is a um a
plastic bag so all the sperm from the
artificial vagina drains into the baby
bottle and into the bag oh inside it's
there's like 35 000 worth of spudgelotti
right like in your hand like a stat
um and uh and yeah the strangest thing
this and my favorite artifact from Dirty
Jobs that I actually auctioned off a few
years ago from my Foundation was that
baby bottle 14 years old
filled with the sperm from this horse
called paid by chick and I and I used to
keep it
I used to keep it on my mantel oh yeah
in San Francisco where I lived in my
apartment and the afternoon sun Theo it
would come through the window and it
would pick up that crystallized semen
and that baby bottle and throw the most
beautiful little rainbows across the
living room unreal little sperm prisms
amazing
anyhow I don't know how we got on this
but yeah man yeah there are lots of
penises out there attached to all
creatures great and small and on Dirty
Jobs we violated pretty much every
barnyard animal you checked them all out
was there a wiener you didn't get to see
was there one of God was there something
off of Noah's Ark you didn't get to see
that hammer uh I'll tell you what I saw
that haunted my dreams for a while was
the joint on an ostrich
looked like a loaf of bread really yeah
no real tip to it just a blunt
instrument
uh which to me explained why you know
they all walk so funny yeah you know
this is brutal
maybe they stick their head in the sand
out of embarrassment they're like oh God
wait till they see what my penis looks
like there are so many things about an
ostrich we could talk for hours about
the ostrich but I saw an ostrich charge
an F-150
the guy had left the door open and tore
the door off the hinge just ripped it
off these things can go from zero to 40
miles an hour and about four steps yeah
their breast plate is about two inches
thick you can shoot it with a 38 caliber
six feet away slug will bounce off oh my
God they're cassowaries right so they've
got their their their claws uh they've
got three claws the guy I worked with
had a one of those big cowboy belt
buckles that had been cleaved in half
right down the middle by an ostrich wow
had that belt buckle not been there the
thing would have killed him they're
dinosaurs right and uh putting the socks
over their heads and leading them off to
slaughter was one of the more exciting
things we ever did that reminds me of a
time I actually went to Guantanamo Bay
actually why to do stand-up comedy
holy crap tell me about that dude so
that kind of blew my mind some guy hit
me up this guy I know he's blind he's
not blind but he's like um
actually he is blind
and he hit me up and he's like hey do
you want to go do stand-up comedy he did
some military tours and he's like you
should go I have the opportunity to go
down to uh Guantanamo Bay and I was like
Jeepers man I have to go do this
so one night we all get in a we get into
Florida in Fort Lauderdale we all get on
a little cess and a plane
and it was like military Pilots or
whatever and then they fly in at this
crazy pattern where it's like because
they can't like they just it's just the
history of how they fly so they it's
less likely to get shot down or whatever
yeah and we're just flying at this crazy
pattern and um
and at first you you don't even see the
base and then it's like the brightest
it's like a diamond in the middle of
nowhere it's like the brightest lights
outline it yeah it looked like a huge
constellation but on the ground kind of
and so almost beautiful from a distance
oh yeah unbelievable look like a damn
wedding ring or something it looked like
the Earth had a wedding ring on
and so we start to land in there and
then next thing you know we're on this
base and there's golf courses there
there's a couple thousand troops there
they have all these like unique bring up
the Guantanamo Bay
um Vehicles like unique vehicle guantano
a gitmo unique vehicle
you're gonna have to get out of the uh
German porno category there and yeah
we're deep in here I mean we're getting
ads popping up I mean we just got a new
Kanye West ad pop-up so not Adidas yeah
um but they have a lot of people oh that
get hit that green room right there that
van
yeah there's like a Scooby-Doo van
there's a lot of unique vehicles down
there it's like one of the weird things
people do on the island is build these
crazy vehicles and drive them around
yeah
um but yeah we stayed there and did
shows for three nights and were you by
yourself no there was three other
comedians this one Yiddish dude who was
a wrestler Mike Burton and there was um
the blind guy and um somebody else too I
think how was it received were they
appreciated
man and the crazy thing was they said
the first day we got there they said uh
yeah I'll take that
thanks very much thanks brother
appreciate it
the first day we got there they said
[Music]
um
oh there's something called gitmo pretty
where the ladies at first you're gonna
be like oh these ladies aren't cute
right but by the third day yeah oh that
lady is a damn she's damn Betsy Ross
dude I'll let her knit my wiener to you
know into a damn stack you know
um anyway so that was it that was really
my but we had a great time and we did
the shows there and people really
enjoyed it and we got to go they have
like beautiful beaches on that like I
didn't realize that we went to this
place I think called Shell Beach where
we swam and it was really cool man so
was that maybe the
the most exotic strangest place you ever
did your your act your thing
that might be man
some of those military base we did like
the Azores one time which is in the
middle of nowhere we did
I did Spain we did China but that's one
of the Cur that's probably one of the
most unique places I've ever done it I
was thinking the other day too somebody
asked me you know where where on dirty
jobs or really anywhere for that matter
you know what's what's the place that
that sticks with you and for me it was
um a place called Cooper Petey in the
Australian Outback where they uh they
mined for Opals
Opals what is it so opal is a it's a
gemstone oh it's a rock yeah it's a it
it's basically a gemstone for um or the
birthstone for October I think but it's
they're very valuable and most of the
Opals in the world come from Australia
and most of the Australian opals come
from this little town called Cooper
Petey uh it was 122 degrees the day we
were there uh the city or it's not a
city but the town is underground people
live underground because it's so hot
it's just so hot and the Flies man the
Flies they're they call them uh stickies
because they'll get on your face and
they and they just don't fly off they
just crawl really quick all over you see
I have to wear these uh these masks
anyway mining for Opals
is they call it Prospect mining so you
dig a hole with something called a
Caldwell bit which is about the
circumference of a manhole cover okay
and they run a shaft about 60 70 feet
deep and then they set up a a pulley and
hook up a boson seat to it it was just a
two by four okay and you sit on it and
then they there you go that's that's the
road to Cooper PD right there the most
dangerous road with the most exotic
roadkill in the world oh yeah dude it is
bananas everywhere you go you'll find
a new Dead Thing by the side of the road
there's a kangaroo they're everywhere
it's like the Austria it's like it's
almost like an Australian it's like hey
if you're gonna die at least die out by
the road so people see you they're so
they're they're so many dead animals and
the Billboards that they show you to beg
you to slow down oh right they're like
shots of guys their faces uh like their
mouths open they're screaming and their
literal toothpicks holding their eyes
open because the people who fall asleep
on the road to Cooper Petey
and and the trucks like we've seen an
eight you know you see 18 wheelers here
all the time they have these things
called truck trains so it's like five 18
wheelers attached to each other yeah and
they'll go 80 miles an hour down the
street who is why is there that guy I
was like man I'm gonna I was I met a
driver one time he's like man I can
drive for 40 straight hours I'm like but
we don't want you to do it just just
because you can't do a thing brother
doesn't mean you should drive for six
hours take a break yeah we'll make you a
sandwich yeah get you a cup of coffee
live alone but it was like God dude I'll
drive for 200 hours dude my dad died out
here and I'm like you're gonna die out
here we're all gonna die man yeah man
your dad don't want you driving for 200
hours
so people love to drive law there's
something about that I can drive forever
what is it I don't know it's like some
like one guy came to me one night he
came to the comedy show he's like man we
drove 24 hours to get here and I was
thinking about where he couldn't have
come from anywhere I'm like then you got
law
like wait a minute would you drive a
tractor the Rickshaw
we own a vehicle with a combustion
engine because I'm not sure I understand
why it took you 24 hours yeah we are
running on briquettes bro look what's
going on here I I think I can explain it
I can bring it back to where we started
yeah going cornhole oh darts
catching crap in midair with a shovel
yeah you know if you're not if you're
not engaged in some great purpose if you
don't have some some sort of overarching
mission in your life then you're gonna
find meaning where where you can find it
yeah and if the only place you can find
it is I drove 24 hours straight to see
you damn damn it it's like okay I don't
wanna I don't want to take that away
from that dude that's that's what he's
got that's what he's selling so hey man
thank you but then he gets on he has to
sleep for two and then he has to leave
he never even got to spend any time but
that's part of the story too yeah I got
there I was so tired I never I never
heard a single joke Theo told me but I
drove 24 hours for that thing I can't
remember my God
um
so what is a what's one of the purpose I
know you talked earlier about I want to
I want to get into like um just some of
the stuff that you're doing we don't
have to get into it what were we talking
about like you mean before we actually
started rolling
were we talking about you have a whiskey
yeah doing a whiskey now called Noble
k-n-o-b-e-l that was based on your
grandfather I thought that was
interesting so dirty jobs was a tribute
to a guy named Carl Noble Carl Noble was
my neighbor and my grandfather
um both of those things both of those
things and he was a magician
um a real magician no as good as they
can be no the kind of magician who you
know the guy woke up clean every day and
came home dirty every night and somehow
during the course of the day something
magical happened something was fixed
something was repaired something was
built the guy could build a house
without a blueprint take your watch
apart put it back together blindfolded a
combustion engine uh a plumbing line
whatever it is right he was born free
he was drug free oh yeah I mean as far
as I know I I never saw him drink to
tell you but he um he only went to the
seventh grade but by the time he was 30
he was the uh Chief electrical inspector
for the state of Maryland licensed
electrician plumber steam fitter
pipefitter welder architect he he could
do all that stuff right so I thought I'd
follow in his footsteps I worked as his
Apprentice for a couple Summers the
handy Gene is uh recessive right so all
the stuff he could do all the stuff he
could do naturally well it it didn't
come easily to me right I I one day I
was working with him on a on a concrete
pour on some construction site and I um
I just bitched up the mix completely
ruined it you know and uh I was probably
16 at the time and he said Mike you know
just because you uh
you can be a Tradesman right just got a
different toolbox yeah and I mean that
that advice changed my life and anyhow
long story short I got in the
entertainment business I I started
pursuing things that I I didn't I I
didn't know I would like and I didn't
know I cared about like singing and
acting and writing and hosting and and
narrating you know I I got into all of
this at a community college as I tried
to put a different toolbox together
and um you know way lead's on the way
and I I freelanced for for 20 some years
in in the TV business had a lot of jobs
and then uh my mother called I was
working for CBS in San Francisco on a
show called evening magazine terrible
little show one of those half hour
things that comes on after the news
right yeah sounds bad it's awful
um but I was good at it you know I was I
was good at creating the illusion of um
of competence in in short course yeah
like Russell Wilson
sure yeah
sure you said it not me
um and so I'm sitting in my cubicle one
day uh preparing for the show that night
and my mom calls me and she says Michael
you know your um your grandfather turned
90 today and he's not gonna be around
forever and I was thinking would it be
great if uh before he died he could turn
on the TV and see you doing something
that looked like work
[Laughter]
my mother no no my my mother hits me
with this right so I take a uh I take
one of my cameramen
uh actually I go to the boss and I say
hey why does evening magazine always
have to be hosted from like a winery or
a or an art museum you know why can't it
be hosted from a a factory floor or a
construction site or a sewer yeah he's
like you want to host evening from a
sewer and I said why not he goes Mike I
don't give a [ __ ] no one's watching the
show do whatever you want so I
I took my cameraman into the sewers of
San Francisco
and what happened down there
um is actually a a book I wrote a couple
years ago it was it changed my life the
um the whole experience in the sewer the
rats the roaches the the just the
endless
chocolate tide that washed over us and
and kept me from doing the job I was
trying to do all of that forced me to do
the only thing I could do which was work
with the sewer inspector who was down
there replacing these rotten bricks you
know that was his job I was just there
to to shoot raps to host the thing
anyhow that footage uh wound up on the
air
and it turned into Dirty Jobs I crushed
and so my granddad saw the first episode
died oh killed him huh killed him killed
my own pop
no yeah he had an amazing life and he he
he lived long enough to see me doing
something that as my mother said looked
like work right and so uh and then Dirty
Jobs blew up yeah yeah and so this this
is you know I'm I'm I know you've seen
this kind of thing in Show Business I
hadn't at that point I'd had a lot of
jobs but I'd I had never gotten mail
from people saying you think that's
dirty you should see what my father does
my brother my cousin my uncle my sister
where do you see this
and that's when I was like oh
oh
this is not a show this is something
else this is um I a love letter to work
it's a romp it's I mean a truly
unscripted you're back before reality
was reality it was like it was a very
unusual thing for Discovery to put on
the air oh yeah when you're in an animal
is that when you're in in an animal's
butt you just no one had ever seen it
and I mean few had and they weren't
supported by by the you know by Society
hey man that that cow still calls me it
is what it is hey Mr fancy man with the
opposable thumb when are you coming back
to town yeah that thing's a
wienermittent that's a wiener mitten so
so for 20 years man I mean the show is
still in production I'm still shooting
Dirty Jobs right now wow and um my
granddad is long gone but I wanted to
you know he he had girls so when he died
his very strange last night female
Offspring you mean yeah okay yeah my mom
and and her sister and I don't know of
any other Nobles k-n-o-b-e-l so this
year with 30 jobs coming back I thought
you know let's let's do something to get
his name out there
and so uh I've got this whiskey and and
we we raise money for the foundation
that was also uh in his honor I do this
thing called micro works and we award um
uh work ethics scholarships to people
who don't want to go for a four-year
degree right but want to weld or be
plumbers or steam Fitters or pipe
fitters or mechanics or electricians or
all the jobs might that my granddad had
yeah my God cousin Ricky is a welder
dude I can't tell you how many people
I've talked to who didn't know what they
wanted to do
but got a welding certificate went to
work and who are now just crushing it
150 Grand a year many of them you know
have picked up their plumbing
certification as well some of them tell
me those dudes are out there they're
killing it yeah I know an underwater
welder 350 Grand last year wow now he's
underwater and he's welding he earns
every penny man I mean he has oysters
for lunch I mean if you've seen Google
Underwater welder and look at what comes
up these guys have big big big stones
and yeah and there's some of them right
there dude now those are the Opals
that's Opals huh those are Opals yeah
those things are worth a fortune God I
want some of that that looks nice
underwater well that's gangster and
being from Louisiana you hear about that
all the time sure offshore rig and
Welding people leaving their families
you hear all of it yeah Louisiana was a
very good to Dirty Jobs over the years
you know before we go there I want to I
want to know a little bit more about
that the uh uh the the grants you guys
give just sure just so just so our
audience can hear about it well
yeah thanks he told me that story about
the about the I I just think it's a neat
story all right so here's what happened
in 2008 Dirty Jobs was the number one
show on cable yeah it it was all over
the world and I was working my ass off
living in motel sixes and super rates
you know I mean on the road full time
they're good but they're bad dude
there's so look anytime you see a hotel
with a number
in its name yeah right I mean in actual
like the number six or the number eight
yeah uh it's no good now now if like
four seasons is different right but they
spell it out right f-o-u-r yeah but if
it's just the number four yeah don't go
in there yeah so I'm I'm living with
hotels with numbers in their names it's
2008. the show's killing it
but the country is starting to slide
into a uh a recession and every morning
I wake up and I walk out of my motel six
and I look you know there's a USA Today
new headline right uh six and a half
percent unemployment seven seven and a
half eight eight and a half nine I mean
for weeks it goes on and all anybody is
talking about or the millions of people
who can't find work and the crazy thing
is on Dirty Jobs back then anyway
everywhere I went I saw Help Wanted
signs so something weird was happening
in the country on the one hand nobody
could find a job and on the other hand
everywhere I went
no one could hire right they couldn't
find people with the skills that were
necessary the welders the plumbers these
these these shortages were real so I
thought maybe I could use the Dirty Jobs
platform
to make a more persuasive case for a lot
of these jobs that were out there that
nobody nobody really cared about and so
micro Works started as a PR campaign for
those trade jobs for skilled labor jobs
that didn't require a four-year degree
and then it turned into a scholarship
fund okay so that's what you're talking
about a few years after that starting in
2012 I guess it was
um we started raising money and to this
day we give away like a million or two
million bucks a year that's awesome in
work ethic scholarships
specifically for people who want to
learn one of these skills yeah so we've
helped uh 17 maybe 1800 people over the
last eight years mostly the construction
trades but this year I've opened it up
to any skill that doesn't require
four-year degree so I don't care
cosmetology cutting hair fine you know
braiding hair fine I just I just yeah
because some of that hair is damn 200
pound test man you know well it's heavy
it is heavy and you know I don't know
what goes on here in uh in Nashville but
down in in Georgia this is terrible you
know there are a lot of black women down
there who make their living braiding
hair but the government had set up this
accreditation thing where you you need
to literally pay like twenty thousand
dollars in order to get a license
to braid hair no yeah so it's like I get
it if it's brain surgery I get it if
you're gonna take my appendix out you
know I'd like to see some diplomas on
the wall I'd like to see some you know
but but to charge a woman
who's trying to feed her kids twenty
thousand dollars for the privilege of
braiding hair that's just freaking
criminal that's cheap so I got angry
about this criminal I mean it's cheap
for the city to do yeah yeah it's just
dumb it's just of all the ways to raise
money why in the world do you want to
tax the people before they've even made
a dollar now I think you should make
those people get tested once a year to
make sure they're decently braiding hair
now that's something I do think because
I've been at the beach before my little
nephew comes back
I mean just looking like he's a you know
he comes back and he's also stolen a car
and I'm like I think they braided this
this is a little too tight over here you
know gotta loosen it up yeah loosen it
up a little bit this guy's forgetting
his morals but you know bad bad braids
are their own bad advertisers nobody
goes back that's true you know so it's
like you know again it's it's it's hair
for Christ's sake so you know yeah
that's a bummer yeah so anyhow that's
you guys opened it up yeah we we opened
all that up and so today when I'm not
working on whatever shows happening I I
Circle back to the people we've given
money to and I asked real probing
questions like how's it going what's new
and dude the answers will [ __ ] make
You Weep I talked to a guy
uh about eight months ago who
I gave him seven thousand dollars he got
his welding certificate I said how's it
going he said let me show you some
pictures so he's hired three of his best
friends they've hired additional people
they got three vans yeah elephants
they're doing it
they're doing welding they're doing air
conditioning and heating they're doing
electric and they're doing Plumbing like
nine dudes uh generating about three
million dollars a year so you know I can
walk all that back from uh a seven eight
thousand dollar welding certificate so
I'm convinced that that's something we
ought to be doing more of and to the
extent I can that that's what I've
decided to do so yeah the money I raise
selling Noble Tennessee whiskey named
after my pop goes into that scholarship
fund and that makes me feel like less of
you know an [ __ ] because sometimes
you're a guy you know holding the penis
of a giant Bulls trying to catch the
white gold and you and you wonder if
your life has any meaning or yeah or
purpose
and then you can maybe you know maybe
help some people who are who are trying
to find their way yeah blue chew have
you been on them
have you tapped into them little blue
chewables baby
dang baby put that low spine in your
pants Bud spawn up that meat
I'm talking about blue chew
it's a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients
as Viagra and Cialis but in chewable
form and at a fraction of the cost get
that cheap
cheap beater
and now they also have Varden Apple mint
flavored chewables
dang boy
imagine having mint in your mouth maybe
in must in your crotch
they got the active ingredient in
Levitra and staxon so you can stay hard
and fresh boy
God he's fresh
the process is simple sign up at
bluechoo.com and consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online that's right and
here's a special deal for you
try Bluetooth free when you use our
promo code t-h-e-o at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code Theo to receive
your first month free a teen solo
hitchhiker
was terrorized for Days by unknown
figures dressed in white
two cops who quit their job at a local
theater because of unexplained
encounters with an alleged demon
and an isolated forest in Canada where
people keep turning up headless
Sans Cabeza
these are just some of the strange dark
and mysterious stories you'll hear each
week on the Mr Ballin podcast that's
right in each episode Mr Ballin shares
real life haunting accounts like the
case of Haley zaga
zaga who disappeared from a hiking trail
for 51 hours
[Music]
Prime members listen to the Amazon music
exclusive podcast Mr Ballin podcast
strange dark and mysterious stories and
the Amazon music app download the app
today yeah no that's amazing man that's
really it's just a neat story especially
when you get that moment where you get
to hear that whatever you did was
helpful and you get to see that you're
like man that's because that's a real
thing in somebody's life like especially
if somebody's struggling where I'm from
the only way to get out if you were
really struggling pressure washing was
the number one thing if you're poor and
I'll say this I've said this for years
and you don't have any money
pressure wash bruh you got a shot
that'll get you that next level you know
it'll get you one stair two stairs up
you know because it's a 600 machine you
get and you can start your own business
and I'll tell you the beauty of pressure
washing is like so many Dirty Jobs you
know how you're doing every step of the
way you're like it's it's the walls a
mess and now it's clean yeah it's like
so
addictive and weirdly satisfying you
know what I did in uh in in Louisiana
once outside of Baton Rouge I went into
a Frack tank right and the guys who
clean the insides of Frack tanks they
not only pressure wash they um what do
you call it when it's when it's not
water that's coming out but these very
very fine pellets like sand washing oh
yeah yeah right so when you blast sand
out of a pressure washing unit it's like
a high-powered shotgun yeah and you can
take the finish off of anything to
finish off your cousin if you want to
probably huh these guys go inside of
these Frack tanks and you're in a you're
in full turnout gear right you're like
in a rubber suit and you've got the
pressure washer and then you've got it
hooked up to this uh you know so you're
blasting out these other little pellets
and that is it's a it's basically a sand
blaster that's what it's called and
there it is that's one of them right
there you know but that thing hooks up
to whatever you want to hook it up to
and man you feel like the Terminator
yeah and so those guys are in there
using those things oh I see wow but see
that's miniature the thing I had really
was as big as a shotgun and you've got
all this compressed air on your back and
you can just take the finish off
anything that ak-40 sand huh that's
exactly right dang now um because I used
to what's a job that I had oh I used to
get in so I used to work on a corn
soybean corn and cotton farm right for
two years so I would get in uh I'd have
to over the winter they would the snakes
would get in rats would get inside of
the
um things that kept the core everything
silos yes rats would get in there and
we'd have to get in there and then
snakes would get in so they'd send me in
there to get like the whatever was dead
right that's a good one yeah but the
thing is 90 of the stuff ain't dead it's
still in there hunting you know I'm
saying we're still in the last Trilogy
of Lord of the Rings right right right
and you're in Mordor and I'm just
rolling up the mountain
with a shovel at four dollars an hour
you know like it was just poor choices
but dude it was the scariest they would
leave me in there they'd be like all
right we'll be back in a couple hours
man get what you can get get what you
can get that should be on a hat too man
because that's it it was so scary
because you'd hear one little thing you
didn't know if it was a mouse or a snake
but either way it was [ __ ] horrible
yeah man yeah it's it's the stuff
sometimes I think it's the stuff that
you can't see you know like a dirty job
spent a lot of time in the animal
kingdom as well and um you know I hosted
Shark Week for a couple of years oh wow
that's crazy and yeah when you're bit by
a shark I mean that's that's a whole
different
I mean that that's so horrifying I I
tested the um one of the first stainless
steel shark suits uh with the guy who
made it wow and they and the shark bit
you oh yeah no we got bit and turned
upside down and shook like a tug toy man
oh it was I honestly that that was the
first time I really saw
um my life flashed before my eyes
because you know like you I'm sure I I
saw Jaws when I was a kid and you know
that that Primal Fear of sharks is in
everybody's brain anything like it's the
same thing with a tiger like a big
full-on tiger anything that can eat you
alive
is will will get you thinking in a
different way oh yeah Kidder Ernesto
that would bite us on the [ __ ] school
bus every day I was so scared of that
that kid alone
Crossing from row like seven to row 11
dude it was
it was are you Euphrates man it was
unbel it was impossible to get past that
guy you had a kid named Ernesto on the
bus oh he would laugh on you bro he
would come out I mean it was like
yeah what he bite the head he bites you
whatever happened to him oh I'm sure
he's probably working for the city
you know but at the time he would bite
the he just had some issues some oral
fixation or something or whatever yeah I
mean look I guess maybe I could talk to
the network and say look you know the
Shark Week thing that you had a good run
you had a good 25 30 years but I know it
dude
Ernesto
I think we do Ernesto a week and we just
see where he is file his teeth down to
really take the stakes up a little bit
make him good and pointy and then just
have Ernesto hide behind a bush and just
jump out and bite people
yeah I mean that's a that's a ratings
Grabber look
I think we start off like rabies
Wednesday we call it I think that's
where we start I don't think we go for a
whole Shark Week
um I interrupted your story though I
don't know where I was going with it
except to say that I've been in silos oh
you were in that suit you were in that
shark suit I was in a shark suit yeah
that's powerful when it grabs you you
can it's really insane it's um it's like
a giant with giant hands
um but but the hands have gloves on like
boxing gloves right and and so the you
you feel all the pressure of that of
those jaws
but the the suit works and that
stainless steel keeps the teeth from
from going through usually okay yeah one
got through I got a call in my shin it's
one one little tooth gets through but
but yeah when they get on your shoulder
and when they got on your elbow they'll
twist you and you will flip upside down
and then they will just shake you like a
rag doll
and that that was in a 2006 all that
happened and all that aired and I
remember watching it at home and feeling
just as terrified as I did when when it
was actually happening and that's weird
because I I know I lived right I mean I
know how the story ends right but it's
it's just the the fear of being eaten
alive is so is so Primal and the guy I
was down there with we were in the
Bahamas and we were kneeling on the
ocean floor
um about 60 feet down oh wow and you're
there with these two big well first
you're on the boat up top and you take
the chum and you throw it yes you just
cover it and the Sharks come dozens of
gray sharks about 10 12 feet long and
they're everywhere and you're in a full
scuba gear and you're dressed up in the
stainless steel suit yeah and um then
when the sharks are right in the middle
of the feeding friends that you jump
you just jump oh my God you jump right
into the center of this swirling mass of
gray Jeremiah the guy who uh who who who
who took me on this freaking
misadventure called them the uh the men
in the gray suits and uh and so you sink
uh to the bottom of the ocean and the
Sharks follow you down and you kneel on
the ocean floor and then you open these
other containers with more blood and
guts in them because the Sharks really
don't want to bite you and whose boat is
this M Night Shyamalan I feel like this
has a I feel like a Titanic
yeah this sounds it sounds biblical and
absolutely ridiculous at the same time
you can find it his name is actually
Stuart Stewart's Cove and it's down in
the in the uh my Bahamas somewhere so
you're kneeling on the bottom so you're
kneeling on the ocean floor and then
boys come up and start nibbling and they
come up they they want the fish in the
blood that you're holding but all you
just do is let it go and sit in the
middle of it and then they'll take you
they'll they'll start biting at you
um and then once they start they really
go for it and I remember looking over I
had a shark on my uh I had one on my
elbow my right elbow and my left knee
and I thought they were just going to
pull me in half like a like a wishbone
and then I looked over at Jeremiah
and he was upside down
sharks all over him and a big one swam
past me right in front of him and the
tail knocked his regulator out
so now this dude is upside down there's
blood in the water yeah I don't know if
it's his mind or the chum uh there's
urine in my suit because all that you
know all that all that happened and uh
you know he's just very calmly got the
thing back in his mouth and lived a
fight another day it was one of the
craziest days really on on Dirty Jobs
ever but uh isn't there something
interesting when you're shooting a show
sometimes it feels like if you died on
the show you'd come back to life in your
regular life did you ever have a feeling
like that the feeling I used to get and
and it didn't happen on this day this is
one of the rare days where it became so
hyper real
that I didn't experience the uh the
bulletproof quality that I'm talking
about like the things I did on camera
the things I was willing to do on camera
I I would never do in real life I'm not
a stunt junkie I'm not like let's go
push the envelope you know right I'm
just a guy who tried to do a show that
looked like work to shut my mother up to
honor my granddad now I'm upside down
with sharks biting me it's like that's
weird right so it's so so when you're
out there in the world you know whether
you're going into an opal mine which is
horrifying or getting bit by a shark or
trying to coax the sperm out of a bull
called huntsucker Commando you don't
you
you don't think you're in real danger
because you're on camera because you're
making a show you're not actually doing
the thing right that's the thing even
pulling my own parachute with the golden
knights you know when I can still hear
the sound of my sphincter slamming shut
at 15 000 feet but you do it because
you're just like there's no way I'm
gonna die on camera right and the
cameras are everywhere and so you do it
now that of course is stupid that's very
foolish but that is a very powerful uh
feeling to answer your question that I
had all the time yeah in that show all
the time
yeah there's something about oh this
isn't I remember one time walking
between two hot air balloons on a plank
right yeah yeah and I was like oh well
if I die I'll just wake up back off
camera
yeah it's not real yes it does not real
yeah it doesn't feel real it feels like
this other Adventure that why were you
doing that man why were you on a plank
between two hot air balloons I was doing
an MTV show and we just had um that was
one of the things we had to do you know
we did some weird [ __ ] man
one time this is a crazy thing we did
one time they had a wood chipper right
we did the opposite I think of what you
did Mike we didn't help Society or or
learn anything this wasn't a job this
was just jackass meets Fear Factor you
know with steaks yeah this was like this
was and they paid us minimum wage too to
do this we made so much money uh for
this for this production company
everything but
um they put animal carcasses in this
wood chipper and then they
um shot it was like a industrial like
the best one you could get I mean like
something God would have you know
and it would shoot the stuff like 60
yards and we had these buckets on our
head remember like a double dare yeah
yeah yeah sure and we had these buckets
on our head and we're trying to catch
the most guts yes the most you could at
literally 60 yards man so we're talking
like Justin a bear throws it or Herbert
throws it you know I don't know how to
say it but
um yeah I remember this one chick caught
a coccyx right in the face man some kind
of damn animal coccyx or something and
uh
you mean the tailbone she was never the
same man
once you get it with a Galaxy you can't
go back from that I mean look a lot of
women want a little bit of coccyx to the
face now and then now and then but I
mean I mean at least she has a story I
mean she's got a scar story what
happened to your face well I'll tell you
what happened yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
hit me about 40 miles an hour
you did a dismembered disembodied coccyx
caught me on the left side of the face
that's amazing that's amazing you know
for me the uh those it's that feeling
that you're sort of invincible in making
a show but every now and then a thing
will happen right so it happened with
the sharks but the one the one I
remember best was um have you ever been
on the Mighty Mac it's a bridge between
the upper and lower peninsula in
Michigan the Mackinac Bridge it's five
miles long it's green I believe in it
I've just never been there it has to be
painted constantly I mean you did they
you never stopped painting the the
minute you finish you just start over
again why what's going on people are
stealing the paint no it's just by the
time you get to the end of it it's two
years later and it needs to be painted
again wow so so I wanted that Mackinaw
Bridge I wanted to paint the Mackinac
Bridge on Dirty Jobs yeah and so they
they they brought me out there and they
let me paint it and it was amazing and
then they let me go into the towers and
down below the water and clean the
inside of these like Honeycombs which is
freaking terrifying
and then at the end of the day I did
something
I asked the question and I knew the
answer would be no but I wanted to ask
the question on camera because I wanted
everybody to know what a badass I was
right so so I say to the guy who was in
charge of the whole thing I said hey uh
before we leave
what do you say uh I walk across that
girder
and step over that stanchion and walk up
that cable see those green cables there
and I said uh you know some somebody
must have to change those light bulbs
um that would be a cool shot because we
have a helicopter with us with a wescam
unit on yeah right and uh and how wide
are those cables those cables are
probably three feet in diameter wow
right so I asked the question knowing
that the guy would say
um well no of course not of course we're
not going to let you do that but he
looks at me and he says okay
[Music]
so I walk across this girder and I start
walking up this cable yeah and so the
way you do it is you tie off on both
sides so you're walking up a hill
you got a clip in your right hand you
got a clip in your left hand there it is
right just like this right okay so I got
a camera screwed to my head shooting
backwards I got that guy
encouraging me to go forward and I got a
bag on my back full of light bulbs that
have to be replaced got it so that
little uh wire that comes up you can see
him those guide wires every 30 feet or
so you have to undo and go around and go
around and the reason you have too is so
that you never are completely not titled
right and so somebody learned that the
hard way you bet they did so right here
you know I'm like all right I'm being
super careful I don't want to fall to my
death I'm uh 300 feet above the road and
600 feet above the water amazing right
and that's a pretty great shot won an
Emmy for that shot actually that's
amazing from a helicopter so we're
walking up there and I'm doing my job
how many gay men love this shot huh
Autumn will take a poll I mean I bet
dude I got a game I'm gonna send him
this later bro it was I mean it was a
big day so what you're seeing now is me
getting increasingly confident as I as I
do the job all right and so you tie off
you tie back on you tie off there it is
that's me doing it properly so at some
point
I get about three quarters of the way up
here and I'm communicating with the
pilot of the helicopter and the
cameraman in the helicopter and we're
trying to get the shot right so that so
the helicopter comes up and this is not
for the for the episode this is for a
promo this is just I I know it's going
to be a great way to promote the episode
so I want to get this shot just right so
I'm sitting uh straddling a uh one of
those stanchions I just replaced the
bulb and somehow or another in the midst
of all the conversation you know the guy
behind me is not in this shot I get him
out of the shot because I'm I'm shooting
my promo right so I want it clean
long story short
um I am holding on to
the statue here the helicopters coming
up like this in front of me I got a
light bulb in this hand and I'm I'm
leaning over right so like between my
toes is 600 feet straight down and I'm
looking at these tankers that look like
toys going underneath the bridge
and I'm sitting there
and up comes the camera and I realize
somehow or another
I'm not tied off to anything
I had unclipped myself and I didn't clip
back in
point of the story is
nothing changes I'm as high as I was a
second earlier
um I'm I'm I'm not doing anything
different I'm simply aware that suddenly
the the safety net is gone right there's
nothing there so
the stakes are higher that's all and
that's the moment Theo when the sound of
your sphincter echoes in your mind right
nothing changes but holy crap you took
your eye off the ball and the cameras
can't save you the helicopter can't save
you you're just an idiot yeah dangling
600 feet in the air right and so yeah
it's it was moments like that
during the show that um reminded me you
know don't don't be an idiot the cameras
actually can't save you and people
people get hurt bad people die every day
doing this kind of work people die every
day I think that's why God made so many
people because
we need repeated examples that people
aren't going to make it it's the Darwin
Awards man
um The Herd gets thin I know huh it's
scary yeah
um what's been something like uh what's
going on with like do you fear because
obviously people tie you in a lot with
like work in class right you get tied in
yeah you know um you know the guy that
was in La Bamba yeah
um I can't remember what's his name
right now Richie Valens is the character
you play but I don't remember his name
right but he always gets invited to all
these Mexican things and he's Native
American right which is so people just
get tied in sometimes to things right
but he goes to these Awards things every
year it's it's awesome right sometimes
it's like uh the screen will make you a
part of things even if you know like in
your story you're almost living your
grandfather's you know some of his dream
right yeah some of yours and some of his
um
but what I'm what I'm saying is like do
you what do you think about like the
future of like jobs and stuff do you
feel like we're in a scary spot do you
feel like that's just hype that we're in
a scary spot no we're in a scary spot
we're in a scary spot
two things first of all
yeah
the visuals will Define you it doesn't
matter what you say it doesn't matter
how hard you work like on Dirty Jobs not
a single episode went by where I didn't
say something along the lines of look
I'm not an expert this is not what I do
in real life I'm here as an apprentice
I'm not here as a host I'm here as a
guest like an avatar my job is just to
try and keep up those guys are the
experts they're the real workers I'm an
actor at least I used to be once upon a
time and before that I was a singer I
sang in the Baltimore Opera for eight
years right like I never I never tried
to hide who I was or right or what I'd
done none of that matters to you because
when you're flicking around and you see
a guy dressed up like a worker wearing a
hard hat doing a job
you make all kinds of assumptions about
that guy yeah and then you know later
when people discover
like you know like it was some secret
that I did some Off-Broadway shows and I
sang I love Newsies okay
but not Glee right okay you're right but
I mean so it's it people today have a
hard time with the cognitive dissonance
that comes from the fact the two things
can be true at the same time it's true
that I sang in the Opera yeah for years
and I had a great time I loved it it's
true that I went to a four-year School
it's also true that I became one of the
loudest proponents for vocational
education in the country right it's true
uh that that I I work on Blue Collar
shows like all these things are true and
so some people have a difficult time
um
processing it right because it's hard to
see people as more than one thing
sometimes too it's like our brain just
wants to make it easy on ourselves
that's right you know what can I what
can I assume from a guy with a haircut
like yours a ball cap a vest
a t-shirt you know the honest answer is
freaking nothing there's nothing to
assume at all but I'm trained to make
all kinds of assumptions yeah and and so
that thing is alive in our culture and
it's alive in our Workforce and it's
it's just bitching everything up because
people simply can't
they they just can't process the
cognitive dissonance of it uh the other
thing is yeah we're we're in real
trouble
um I had a guy on my podcast uh just a
couple weeks ago an economist named
Nicholas Everhart okay this guy is
brilliant Harvard all the abbreviations
after his name that you want uh American
Enterprise Institute wrote a
best-selling book in 2016 called men
without work just republished it because
the contention in the book is now on
steroids wow and basically what he's
saying is
never mind the unemployment numbers they
don't matter that's a Depression era
metric and it doesn't tell us anything
we really really need to know here's
what we need to know 7 million
able-bodied men between the ages of 25
and 54.
are not only not working
they are not looking they're
affirmatively not looking for work never
in the in in peace time
never has that metric existed before we
have four million more open jobs today
than we did pre-pandemic and we have
four million fewer people in the
workforce
it's really bad and you can't find an
employer
in anywhere today who is not desperate
to hire so like that that's actually
happening so some of the things that I
hear when I'm out and about you know
um you hear from some people that
they're not paying enough right oh sure
um and then you hear from other people
that if they weigh if they raise the
minimum wage in some job and some uh
businesses then it'll kill the business
sure
um I think greed is also probably a big
problem that's happened in this country
it's like we don't you don't want the
man who's working with you to also have
success at some point it's like it's
exactly what we just said about two
things being true at the same time and
people
struggling with it
it is
it is true that lots and lots of people
are out of work it is true that even
more people
aren't looking for work if I tell you
that there are 11 million open jobs in
the country right now that's not
political that's just a fact yeah and no
one can dispute it no one does dispute
it but what immediately happens is my
buddies on the left to your point when I
say why do you think there's so much
opportunity here that can't be filled
they'll say because
because business owners are Pricks
they're greedy and they're rapacious and
if they paid more money those jobs would
fill
my buddies on the right when I ask them
the same question will say because
people are lazy people are just lazy
they don't want to work they won't show
up early they won't stay late they won't
take a bite of the [ __ ] sandwich when
it's their turn they won't do the thing
that needs to be done
so that's how it becomes politicized it
doesn't change the fact that there's
still 11 million open jobs but if we
want to argue that the jobs are open
because the opportunities are shitty
versus the jobs are open because people
don't want to work
then we're going to paint with a really
broad brush and we're not going to solve
the problem the truth is exactly as you
said it sure greed factors into it but
so does work ethic you know my
Foundation offers work ethic
scholarships because I think I think
work ethic actually is under siege and I
don't think it has as much to it has
something to do with Benefits it has
something to do with pay
but but it's not just that it's it's a
real clear and present uh aversion
to to getting in there
and you know and I mean I I don't care
if it's blue collar or or white collar
you know I
my work ethic whatever that means
um I I learned it as a kid I learned it
from my pop and and it's got nothing to
do with the trades your work ethic how
many shows you do a year how many
podcasts do you do we did a mirror for
years I did I put in a I put in my work
you know and I still do you still do
yeah and I still want to make it better
and you are and and like to me I mean I
don't know a ton about your career but
the thing I like a lot about everything
you've done is that you're actually a
fairly serious person and you and you
have
uh you have a platform and you have
listeners and you have the ability to do
things and say things that might
actually help somebody and you're doing
it right and and you're not doing it for
a metal you're not doing it for a prize
you don't have to do it though you know
you don't have to do any of this right
so you know I I admire that and and the
people that my Foundation tries to help
have that quality right and I'm sorry
but I got to put my I put my thumb on
the scale too and I say if you're if
you're not willing to take a bite of the
[ __ ] sandwich from time to time then why
should I give you money that people
trust me to dispense
judiciously and and and fairly you know
so I am in a weird spot people get angry
at me a lot now because they're like
well who are you I got this thing called
a sweat pledge all right some people
love it some people hate it and what is
that from like a sigma new or something
so I'd I had a couple drinks one night
and like eight years ago and I was
trying to figure out what what can I do
to to get people to talk about work
ethic how can I challenge them you know
I can't look into their soul
but like what are 12 things that I
believe
are true uh and and really impact
people's success so I wrote these 12
things down sweat I stood for something
a skill and work ethic aren't taboo
right it was just a thing to get high
school kids
thinking and talking about the value of
an honest day's work and um you know it
said the sweat pledge says things like I
think the first one is um
I believe I've hit the greatest Lottery
of all time I'm alive I live in America
above all things I'm grateful all right
so
I feel that way and I understand that
life's not fair and I understand that
other people feel different ways but but
if you don't fundamentally feel
jazzed and psyched and excited by this
brief little time you've been given to
fog a mirror and walk around on this
planet man if you're not stoked by that
I can't help you I don't I don't want to
help you yeah I don't because because
there are other people out there who are
showing up early and staying late there
are people out there who understand uh
delayed gratification they understand
they understand the most important rungs
on the ladder you mentioned the minimum
wage
I get [ __ ] for this all the time but
it's like those those minimum wage jobs
you know they're not meant to be careers
right they're they're meant to be a
thing you do for a time so you can learn
about that thing and get paid something
for your trouble you know those lower
rungs on the on the ladder they're
they're important right because they get
you to the middle but you shouldn't
monkey around there forever if you can
help it and and you should try to help
it look again
cookie cutter advice is dangerous right
everybody's different and there's
outlier circumstances we'll have
children they don't have any other
choice that's not who you're suggesting
to it's like but if someone's gonna just
sit at that position and then complain
about it uh then it kind of creates a
different set of circumstances here's
the scary thing about Nick eversat's
conversation with me the thing that
really stuck it wasn't that seven
million able-bodied men
are affirmatively not looking for work
it's what they're doing instead
and there's a lot of research on this
vaping
worse what they're doing instead and
this and this data by the way comes from
self-reporting
surveys so this is what the seven
million men have
have explained is is taking up all their
time
ninety percent of them are spending over
2 000 hours a year on screens yeah
now 2080 hours
that's 40 hours a week that's a
full-time job
these guys are spending a full-time jobs
amount of time
on screens
well here would be my thought and at
some point was our government and I know
this is like people are going to say
well you can't respect your government
to take care of you and this and that
and I don't either I don't expect I
don't expect my government to take care
of me I've take care of myself but at
some point was there supposed to be some
protection against the addiction to
screens like it's obviously dangerous
for us people die because they're
texting people are losing their human
instincts because they're human connect
you know it's it's so obvious yeah it's
like
it's not that obvious it's obvious now
but you know it's it's you got to think
of it like prohibition you know people
looked at booze and got to the point
where it became undeniable that it was
destroying lives and so uh in the 1920s
we just decided that's it no more booze
we're going to prohibit it well that
ain't gonna work you know because not
everybody wrestles with the same problem
the same way
and you can cross out booze and write in
porn cross out porn and vaping and write
in vaping cross that out and write in
you know and so but then all of a sudden
you get to Fentanyl
and now no your your experience is not
going to vary you're going to die right
right and and and then put in screens
now there's something different about
screens it's it's the addiction and it's
the fun of it
I mean look I I literally I sat on the
ball the other day and I don't like the
Linger on the bowl longer than necessary
yeah you cramp up my circulation I can't
walk away from it you stand up and you
fall down like a cheap card table
because I'm sitting there on Tick Tock
or reels yeah just like kind of and
that's suddenly I got 20 minutes I
stopped crapping 20 minutes ago and
there I sit right that
and and look it's addict it's and they
created the algorithm beyond what we can
we can't even handle it anymore but you
turn that on you go into it dude I'm 60
years old okay
um I I have had a certain amount of
success in my life I've seen a lot of
things I'm not a foolish person I sat on
the bowl for 20 minutes until I lost my
circulation looking at this thing yeah
all right and I'm busy
I got five shows going on I do a podcast
I'm running a foundation I'm trying to
launch a line of whiskey I'm busy but I
sat there for 20 minutes as all the
blood left my legs yeah you know waiting
to see the next little magic trick
where'd the next guy take a pie in the
face yeah what the [ __ ] what what is
that right and so there is something
about the screen
that is different than booze and
different than porn and different than
all these other things that came along
that would keep an otherwise busy
sensible man sitting on the bowl wasting
time so why are seven million people
sitting home doing this because they
like it because it's fun because they
can
you know so
you know oh and the other thing you said
before I think is so true it's the it we
all want feedback remember early on we
were talking about the feedback from a
podcast the feedback from a TV show the
amount of time you have to wait to see
did it rate we're gonna wait for Nielsen
we're gonna wait for pod track we're
gonna wait for somebody somewhere to let
us know
if what we did worked you can post this
conversation with you and me right now
on YouTube or wherever it goes and know
in real time how we're doing yeah you
could just watch it happen and man
that's addictive too for me that's
interesting because we all want feedback
we all want to know how we're doing and
there's the the screen offers something
like that yeah how pissed do you get how
impatient do you get when you text
somebody and they don't text you right
that's unreal it's not like what
happened don't give me the three dots I
see I know you read it
I know I know you read it but what you
doing you know what they're doing
they're sitting on a toilet watching
some [ __ ] with respect walk a plank
between two balloons watching yeah yeah
no you're right we're watching autism
construction that's what I watch all
this I'm just like wood you know bird
houses and a lot of you know I get
caught into that world but um uh one
thing it's also interesting it's
interesting Mike we used to go to our
grandparents for a skill you know we
used to go to like if you needed a skill
you had to be an apprentice if you
needed a skill you had to go to a Master
of the skill and get it you know and
then now with like YouTube and how-to
videos that's become everybody's
grandfather that's become everybody's
father in a lot of ways we've we've
killed not killed but we've hampered the
the skill sets and the connective pieces
that even connected uh Fathers and Sons
and mothers and daughters dude that is
you know I call it the death of grout
the grout is the stuff that connects the
tiles it's the connective tissue you
know and and we haven't to your point
eliminated it but but we've replaced it
so Zoom learning is not the same as
classroom learning and YouTube
instruction
is not the same as Hands-On
apprenticeships and it there's nothing
inherently wrong with zoom or YouTube
but they're selling it to us like it's
the same thing
and that's a lie it's like that movie
you ever see pet cemetery uh oh yeah so
the cat what was his name uh church
right the cat that comes back to life
that's a bad cat dude right I mean yeah
the cat dies they bury it and it comes
back and of course the same thing
happens with their kid and that's what
these things are their versions of the
original like multiplicity like Michael
Keaton like he keeps cloning versions of
himself and each one gets dumber and
less competent and more entitled and
more tragic and so yeah you can replace
these things with these other things but
there's going to be hell to pay there's
always going to be an unintended
consequence I don't care if you're
talking about rent control or the
minimum wage or Zoom learning for school
learning right there's there's
it's a poor substitute it's a substitute
you know rent control is a poor
substitute for self-sufficiency a
minimum wage is a poor substitute for
people who refuse or can't leave the
rung
where they're standing you know you just
wind up enabling the very kinds of
behavior that that we all know we'd like
to improve yeah and so that's that's
that's what I think about today you know
when I'm not trying to get the sperm out
of a bowl called hunsucker Commando yeah
look I masturbated yet 11 hours ago so
yeah how'd it go it went like it goes
yeah you know that's the problem with it
it's like right when you're done you're
like uh I knew it was gonna be just like
that yeah but I mean do you feel like I
thought it actually you know what
actually I'm gonna quit saying that you
know what dude good job you crushed it
and I didn't take it super easy I
freaking you know I kind of made it you
know I I made it a little bit more
exciting than usual nothing insane you
know because I was trying to get to
sleep but well I mean but who you're
trying to impress really I mean that's
that's the thing if if you get too
wrapped up in the performance of
self-abuse then you lose the
authenticity I think you do way to land
the plane and bring it back to where we
started and talk about immediate
feedback you know how you're doing you
know yeah you do you always know how
you're doing when you're rubbing one out
you know it's just like ah you know what
this is this is not going well you know
maybe you got the wheel of options
that's spinning right you're like ah
maybe this maybe I'll stop here maybe
I'll stop there yeah Mom what are you
doing there get off that thing that's
that's no good and then suddenly it's
like you know something I'm just gonna
go to sleep that's a bad one right yeah
that's a bad one that's a bad one
um I had one last question how close are
we before you have to go I don't know
what time is it it's 1205 I have to pee
really bad to you I could pee yeah
oh there was one question I wanted to
ask you before we move on how how did
globalization really ruin us
because a lot of times I think like you
know Mike I think like like my mom grew
up in Wyoming Illinois right it's a
small town yeah and uh there are some uh
they used to have I think FMC they made
like Elevator Parts and stuff like that
or like the gang planks that go from the
plane to the terminal yeah
um and my grandfather worked over there
and
um Purina was like in like some of the
nearby towns in Iowa and had like
offsets in Illinois
and it was interesting because it was
like as a kid your dad worked at the
factory and so you had a piece of Pride
and whatever oh well this dog food they
my dad they make that at the factory or
this table oh they make that at the
factory and
um so there was a sense of like what you
were using you there was just a
connectivity a fabric of it all it was
local yeah it's the grout we were
talking about
the grout is the you know it it holds
communities together it holds zip codes
together it holds towns together States
together and it holds the country
together will it hold the world together
well I don't know I I'm suspicious of it
because you know there's some very very
big differences between this country and
Russia and China and Iran and the UK and
France for that matter but we're we're
not we're not fundamentally different as
a species but we're fundamentally
different
as a society yeah and so you know when
you say has globalization wrecked the
country
you know my my slip is showing here a
little bit but I'll tell you I I look at
it like if you had a gifted and talented
kid
really smart right how would you feel
about putting him in a public school
you'd you'd worry right you'd look you'd
look at him or her and you'd be like I
don't I don't think that this is the
best environment to nurture the the
qualities my my kid has right right so I
I look at our economy that way our
economy is gifted and talented we we
built an amazing machine in this country
in in the 20th century we were not
dependent on foreign powers we were not
dependent on foreign countries
especially foreign countries who
affirmatively seem to hate us yeah right
so that's a bigger part of it I don't I
don't personally feel good
knowing that our
our
pharmacological needs
are completely dependent on China
I don't yeah me either I don't feel good
about that I I don't feel good about the
fact that your your granddad or whoever
was making those jet ways you know those
jetways aren't made there anymore right
you know Purina is not Purina anymore
um and so in almost every industry
there's been a hollowing out you know
it's easy to talk about manufacturing
and I do that all the time with my
Foundation because you can go through
the Rust Belt and through Appalachia and
you can see we're just not making that
kind of thing here anymore oh yeah and
it's heartbreaking it I I think it's
heartbreaking because
because we're in this space where
everything is designed to please the
consumer and we forget that workers are
also consumers
so they're the problem is in my view
everybody in the country is a consumer
but not everybody is a worker
and consequently
you what can you say about the reality
of walking into a Walmart and being able
to purchase everything you need at a
really affordable price that's all made
possible because that stuff is not made
here right and so we we made a decision
we made a bargain decades ago
that says all right we're going to put
our gifted and talented kid
into this low performing school yeah and
we're going to pay the price for that
but we're also going to enjoy what comes
back which is abundant free stuff bad
shelving yes bad shelf right but I mean
I don't like as much bad shelving as you
want that's right all you can eat you
know you know the good news is you can
have all you can eat the bad news is
you're going to the Golden Corral all
right
you're not I mean with respect no
offense but but you know what I mean
it's like it's it's all you want of
stuff you that doesn't really nourish
you and stuff that doesn't mean anything
and then I wonder like in China or some
of these places and I'm obviously
generalizing but that's okay because I
don't know that much you're a podcast
dude you can generalize yeah and I miss
the days being able to [ __ ]
generalize because I don't know what I'm
talking about so I'm bringing them back
um but in China that that guy doesn't
care about the sweater he's making for
somebody a million it doesn't you know
he so then he leaves work there's no
there's is no spirit in any of it
there's no like dude that's brilliant
and you're right and it kills those
people her that kid's dad comes home
from work and the look in his eyes is
like oh I made something for somebody A
Million Miles Away that I'll never even
know and don't even care about back to
the feedback we were just talking about
if you don't know how you're doing right
whether
you're hosting a TV show or a podcast or
rubbing one off 11 hours ago yeah right
right if you don't know how you're doing
you're going to be disconnected from the
task at hand and I it that's a really
smart observation if you spend your days
and nights making widgets for people you
never meet
then you will never be connected to
anything other than the transactional
brute realities of your job and that
sucks and that's why so that's why I
stay out of Labor disputes you know
because
unions have an argument to be made and
and so too does does capital and and
people who take the risk to create the
companies right the these two things
can't be enemies but we continually talk
about them like it's constantly won
against the next and in the midst of all
that screaming past each other what do
we do we become more and more dependent
on cheap crap made in China more and
more dependent on
really important things now our whole
supply chain is baked in to the
globalization that that you're talking
about yeah and dude don't even get me
started on energy how dependent you know
how much do you want to pay for gas
really I mean how what are we doing why
are we relying
why are we relying on anyone
other than us we could do it yeah we
could build the factories back we could
do it I'm not saying don't trade I'm not
saying be isolationist right I'm saying
you're going to negotiate from a much
stronger position if you don't need them
yeah it's fine to want them but if you
need them you're screwed and I don't
know why we would put ourselves in a
position where we need pipelines that
run through countries that hate us when
we're sitting on an absolute
abundance of affordable reliable energy
right now it makes me crazy yeah
yeah there's a new company I was reading
about called vespain actually and they
take they process
um the methane gas yeah and uh they put
something over a landfill that processes
it and turns it currently into Bitcoin
mining but eventually we'll be able to
create like a gas station that will
power you have energy to power vehicles
yeah I've seen it it's um
it's related to carbon recapture so
there's some big big companies now uh
that are taking the carbon that is
generated from fracking right and
Blasting it back in to the earth
I mean it's it's unbelievable technology
and it's going to wind up leaving Big
energy companies carbon neutral like in
the next couple of years I know it's
crazy it's crazy yeah there's one that
does it for fracking and then this is a
new one that's doing it with uh the
methane I think from and and look I'm
speaking I'm not a I don't know about
this stuff but I know about the uh the
excitement of um young companies like
this and like just the novelty dude good
for you and look I people tell me
whenever I get into this world it's like
hey man why don't you just stay in your
lane right well you know what my Lane is
I'm addicted man I am an addict I am
addicted to smooth roads and affordable
electricity and indoor plumbing doing
you know we all have skin in this game
and mediocre coffee and mediocre coffee
that gets cooler and cooler every second
um but look I
I think it's great that you're talking
about
vespine in fact you should call him get
him a sponsor yeah not a bad idea
brought to you by vespine I'll do the
voiceover if you want man yeah I've
heard your voiceovers pretty no no it's
a top dollar voice it's all right I've
got some uh that's some uh that's some
95 octane high above the vast reaches of
the barren Serengeti the bald eagle
watches as the lonely wildebeest wanders
away from the herd as a very first thing
I ever got paid to do a a nature
documentary for uh for National
Geographic I was 22 and they thought I
was like 40. yeah that's funny God yeah
oh I bet dude I bet you could buy beer
just Beauty if they walk in they just
had to open the door and be like I'll
take two cases of Bud Light
yeah like uh any ID sir no thank you
just give me the beer
I don't have a lot of time yeah I don't
have a lot of time but I'm pretty
thirsty do you ever remember buying was
there ever do you remember the first
time you bought beer illegal or no uh I
do uh I walked into a place called The
Old Philadelphia Inn I was probably uh
16 years old with my friend Jeff Wilson
and
um Jeff uh wrestled uh he was a 230
pounder High School just a mountain of a
guy yeah and I sounded older than I was
and they didn't even blink boom they
sold it to us
hell yeah damn right
it's a simpler time for you it was so
much fun wasn't it it was so scary
remember how scary it was oh my God I do
and remember when you give them if they
did ask your ID you'd give it to them
and then try to look like you were older
right like checking my watch I got
somewhere to be uh my son I'd say that
to my buddy I'm staring there with ah my
son he has epilepsy had makeup they're
like what that collection eight months
old with that this guy needs a drink
somebody help him God I missed that is
there a sport that you really like I
just went to a LSU game the other day
yeah uh I played baseball
um through through high school and I
still watch it
um I was a big football fan I grew up in
Baltimore oh yeah
um and you know it's really interesting
I go back to Baltimore a lot now
um and somebody asked me the other day
uh if I'd seen the Ravens game
it was a Sunday and they they just
played
and I didn't and and they're like how do
you not know what the Ravens did you're
back in Baltimore and I told him the
truth I said you know in in March of
1986 uh
I was about the biggest Colts fan there
was seasoned tickets I was dating a
cheerleader
um and my best friend played in the
Colts marching band and one night
Robert irsay sent the Mayflower Vans at
three in the morning
and the next day they were gone
they're just [ __ ] gone man and I
couldn't believe it and to answer your
question something happened to me with
with big organized professional sports
and it happened in March 1986 when the
Colts left in the middle of the night
that's when I realized
uh the players have their agents and
managers and the owners have their
lawyers but the fans have nothing the
fans have nothing and the degree the
degree to which that team the extent
that they that they mattered to to
Baltimore you just can't overstate it
and like that they were gone and for
that reason I've never had an agent I've
never had a manager it it changed the
way I thought about Show Business it
changed the way I thought about sports
and to really bring it back to where we
started that's why I watch cornhole
and darts
that's probably why I was catching poop
in midair yeah it was it was simpler it
was pure it was like I you know Fresh
Off The spigot yeah man you know what
I'm saying though really pure it's like
how pure can this get I agree the NFL
feels so unpure these days a lot of it
feels I love UFC became my favorite
sport in the past few years especially
during the pandemic yeah I think because
of some of the purity of the the fight
getting to know some of the fighters and
just seeing what it is it's mono imano
out there you know so I was in the guy
who produced dirty jobs with me
originally uh Craig peligian was his
name was the same guy who produced The
Ultimate Fighter for Spike TV and the
boxing show uh no Ultimate Fighter Dana
White's oh okay Ultimate Fighter all
right now yeah I walked in Craig's
office one day uh halfway through the
first season of Dirty Jobs and there was
this big bald dude
and they were finishing up a deal
and I I walked in just in time to see
him shake hands and then Dana looked at
me and he was like hey man I enjoy your
show and I'm like well thanks What's
your deal he told me what he was doing
and I just said very casually to Craig
um I said hey man I do the vo for that
that sounds like fun
I did 12 seasons of The Ultimate Fighter
wow previously on The Ultimate Fighter
yeah right it was just that stuff and um
I I really never got to see one but I
would go into the booth every week and
there was always a stack of copy and
somebody The Ultimate Fighter was always
in there so my whole uh experience in
that world was just narrating it and I
hadn't I didn't even see the show for a
couple of seasons and then I sat down
and I watched and I was like holy crap
man this is why boxing is over Don
hey this is why it's over back to the
authenticity it's like yeah you're not
fixing that fight right right that's
what it seemed like there's no way to
fix it nope nope no easy way and you
know I
I it was amazing to watch that that
happen that to bring back that level of
uh Gladiator Nest yeah you know what I
mean it's listen it it a lot of people
have strong feelings both ways but I
think that was in our culture one of the
early uh indicators that people were
hungry for something else
right people were hungry for something
that was real because reality was no
longer real nope non-fiction was
[ __ ] yeah there were no podcasts yet
no no Joe Rogan wasn't doing his thing
uh back when that started so you know
you we've lived to see like some huge
huge changes and your your audience is a
part of it you're a part of it and it's
it it's a trip to watch it and I can't
wait to see what happens next yeah
yeah me either I think about that time
do you think we are Mike Sager
somebody's picking me up in three
minutes yeah so I get I got three
minutes to say something like really
really really Unforgettable hmm
let me think if there was something I
would want to know
[Laughter]
oh dear I'm tapped out all right no
longer curious do you remember your
first kiss ever in life I do yeah yeah
uh her name was Donna oh
I met a girl
yeah God and believe it or not it was
spin the bottle God was it huh yeah man
and uh it was dark and I spun it and it
landed where I wanted it to land god and
I remember scooting myself across the
the shag carpet in the basement and she
scootered herself toward me
and uh
God yeah it was uh it was it was
something else yeah there was something
else
that was a good one how about you
um there was I think one time some
people I think locked us in a room one
time me and this girl that had this she
had like this kind of chip tooth this
Lloyd Christmas going on you know this
girl named Chrissy beautiful girl I
don't but a part of me doesn't know if
there was it was either that or this
other time we played a spin the bottle
game
and there was this girl named Emily
or was her last name nice oh we're doing
last names now well and I'm going to
take that out
[Laughter]
but man she looked like a million Angels
dude she looked like I could close my
eyes and see her even more brighter than
I could see her if I was looking right
at her yeah and uh and I and I was like
oh my God she's really gonna do it I
hadn't I just thought any girl laying
around they weren't really gonna kiss me
you know like I just felt like such a
failure in that space and um and I got
close to her and I'd only seen people
kiss like by opening their mouths and
kissing like french kissing or something
and so I like went at her like a fish
you know like you're taking a bite out
of an apple dude and not like I put my
mouth my mouth like over yeah and it
made no sense and everybody was like
what's happening and I think it just got
it just went downhill I kind of like
what like you know I did the same thing
but not on my first kiss there was a
girl a couple like maybe a year later
and I realized that every kiss I had
ever attempted up to that point I was
doing what you were doing not not to
that extent but I was always on the
outside of of their lips you know what I
mean I was yes it made me feel like okay
but this girl her name is Debbie I'm not
using the last name because you might
not take it out but she had it in her
head that that her job was to be on the
outside of my lips
so the first couple of times we tried to
make out it really looked like two
people trying to eat each other's heads
yeah right it's just it's bigger and
bigger and wider and wider and but
eventually both her mouths are as open
as they can be with these awful tongues
just flailing around it just nose to
nose and I remember opening my eyes and
seeing that her eyes were open and she's
like what are you doing I'm like what am
I what are you doing you don't know how
to make out you know we should probably
just start groping it's simpler
it's it's a simpler time like some blind
betta fish huh
dude and I remember this to be I tell
you this man one girl she let me uh like
touch her like chess kind of we were
like probably 14. I don't know what we
were but they 34. yeah
her uh dad was a uh Elvis impersonator
right uh-huh but we live in a small town
you don't need one you know so he just
really was an alcoholic and he kept his
kids in an electric fence in their yard
and this girl let me feel her boob
through that electricity through the
electrical just on top of her dress okay
man look still counted that's where we
have to probably I mean look it's your
show I gotta go yeah but but I mean that
that's one of the greatest metaphors of
all time reaching through an electric
fence
to gently cup the breast of a young love
so you're surrounded by consequences you
got danger everywhere you're you're
being allowed to do a thing
but there's risk right there's risk all
around you I was at my cousin's once and
uh we had to pee just like we had to pee
here 20 minutes ago and my cousin son of
a [ __ ] he uh he said yeah let's just
this is a good place to go and uh he had
an electric fence that kept their uh
their their horses in
and I don't know what he said to make me
think it would be okay but I peed on the
electric fence
and the current that ran back up through
my stream of urine straight into the
very
essence of my middle God knocked me it
knocked me on my ass and um
I still remember this day this is one of
the most awkward moments of my life
lying on my back next to my cousin
laughing hysterically as the urine
continued to shoot straight up in the
air like a horrible yellow Fountain and
I just lay there and cow [ __ ] peeing on
myself
and that's fracking
that's why we power washed guys Mike
thank you so much man we'll uh what's
your podcast called we want people to
check it it's called the way I heard it
it's on every week it's uh it's it's a
little different than this but you know
what in the end it's uh
I I think we're trying to do the same
thing man just tell the truth to the
people who got the balls to hang out and
stick with you for two hours amen micro
thank you so much Brother anytime to you
appreciate it yeah now I'm just just on
the breeze
I must be
Cornerstone
[Music]
I'll share this piece of my life
[Music]